Lincoln says he expressed Washington's
commitment to finding a peaceful
resolution to last month's military
takeover the coup leaders have refused
diplomatic appeals to return to civilian
rule Charles Stratford has Moana from
Dakar in Senegal
which of Nigeria's capital Naomi
remained calm but the military coup
leaders show no sign of backing down
instead announcing more new officials to
replace the government of democratically
elected president Muhammad bahrazum who
they have held in detention since July
the 26th the president the president of
the National Council for the
safeguarding of the Homeland head of
state decrees Article 1 Mr lamin Zane
Ali Mohammed is appointed prime minister
all diplomatic efforts at finding a
peaceful solution to the crisis have so
far failed in its latest response the
military Junta said it had refused entry
to a delegation from the African Union
the U.N and the regional block ecowas
because of security concerns
this only hours after the acting U.S
deputy secretary of state Victoria
Newland said she had held two hours of
difficult talks with a self-appointed
defense minister and had been refused
access to niger's detained leader the
U.S says it Still Remains hopeful
diplomacy can work the window of
opportunity is definitely still open we
believe that uh the Hooters should step
aside and allow president bazoom to
resume his duties tomorrow today
tomorrow anytime in the near future
ecowas is struggling to pull together a
military force comprised of soldiers
from member states which it has
threatened to use as a last resort in a
potential military operation to
reinstate the deposed Nigerian president
Nigeria's president Bola tinubu is the
new chairman of ecowas
Nigeria with by far the biggest army in
the region would be expected to take the
lead in any such military operation
but president tinubu is facing
opposition from Nigerian MPS including
those in his own party and his people
who fear the considerable risk of
sparking a wider Regional War
and if that were to happen it could lead
to a deterioration in the already
difficult fight against armed groups
like Boko Haram isil and Al-Qaeda we
have multiple levers on which we can
leverage uh to achieve uh the end uh
that we are seeking to achieve which is
to uphold the ecowas protocols by
ensuring that there is a return of
Civilian Democratic rule under the
leadership of President bazoom the
refusal by niger's coup leaders to allow
entry into the country by a combined
United Nations African Union and ecowas
delegation comes two days before a
second emergency ecos Summit on the
crisis it's expected the focus of that
Summit will be discussions about a
potential Last Resort military solution
The Diplomatic Avenues are still open
but there are fears that they are
becoming increasingly slim Charles
Stratford Al Jazeera the car
the U.S state department has given more
details on the call between Anthony
blinken and the Australia president
Muhammad bazum
I I will speak to the conversations the
secretaries had with president bazoom
and in those conversations the secretary
has number one looked for an assessment
of the situation from president bazoom
um number two he's been checking on his
safety and his health and the health and
safety of his family uh and number three
he has been reassuring him that we
support the return to the Constitutional
order and that is the position of the
United States and that is what we are
trying to work towards
is the U.S still in a position of not
calling what's happening in major
accrual
it is at this point an attempted
military takeover but again we do not we
are still working to achieve a different
outcome and we are hoping to
see President bazoom released from house
arrest and able to to resume his duties
as we heard they're members of the West
African vote Echo us will be gathering
in Nigeria's capital on Thursday let's
get uh more on this now with aqua Idris
who's in abujah Ahmed what can we expect
from this meeting tomorrow then given
that the coup leaders have shown no sign
of seeding power
well basically a lot of people expect
the leaders to
stick to the Diplomatic solution to
allow it more time but again we expect
to see more sanctions coming into effect
whether or not that will succeed it's
not clear at the moment but we are
hearing right now that inflation has
gone through the roof in Niger Republic
electricity has been cut off so a lot of
people are out of jobs especially small
jobs that depends on electricity to
generate income so leaders will try to
leverage on that they will try to
squeeze Niger more and more tightly so
as to gain some kind of concessions from
the cool leaders however it's looking
increasingly clear that diplomatic
Solutions may not resolve this crisis
anytime soon military option Nigeria
says is still on the table some sources
even have gone far to say that the
troops on this side of the Border are
ready in case there is an order or a
goal from the military from the heads of
state in the region so the meeting
tomorrow will basically look at
development since the last meeting here
in Abuja whether or not they will allow
more time for diplomatic Solutions but
that diplomatic solution is increasingly
looking uh unlikely at the moment and
what about then divisions within ecowas
itself over what should happen going
forward
well among the member states whether
whether or not there are divisions these
have not been sort of underlined clearly
or in public uh there are some countries
who may not who will not I mean who will
not participate in any military action
against Leisure and even Nigeria the
largest contributor of forces there are
divisions within the community within
the Nigerian Community people are
mostly against any military action in
Nigeria but again for ecowas what
options are there sanctions well
sanctions have not worked in Mali
sanctions have not worked in Burkina
Faso and they're also not working in
Guinea so basically the only option for
many uh for many of the heads of state
angling for a quick resolution of this
conflict will be the military option but
who is going to fund these uh military
activities in Nigeria uh basically these
countries are really really going
through a tough time economically they
cannot at the moment uh devote a lot of
funds away from the development projects
to a military action in Nigeria Republic
but a lot of political analysts in the
region we've spoken to says the air
course has already shot itself in the
foot since the beginning since the coup
in Mali it was dilly-dally putting
sanctions and lifting sanctions and some
people believe that the presence of
technical advisors military advisors
from Mali and Burkina Faso especially
Indonesia at the moment is sort of
making the uh Asia co-leaders more and
more stubborn so basically they don't
expect to see any resolution through
diplomatic means because these two
countries realize that if Niger is
resolved quickly then there will be more
pressure on them to relinquish power to
civilian administrations in Mali and
Burkina Faso and probably Guinea as well
okay thanks for that update live for us
from Abuja thank you